the Joe Rogan experience Wow the police
were there and when did you start doing
albums with Cheech which is 71 I had
that all hot to take place while we came
down lay in 70 and we struggled when all
the places we did we could work then we
started being a regular at the
troubadour they had hootenanny night
Sunday night was I mean what's
hootenanny is when folk singers would
get on some tension singers sing a song
hootenanny hootenanny hootenanny night
and so all the singers would saying you
know and so we would get up and do
comedy and of course we became regulars
you know in fact the troubadour would
phoned us up and say are you guys coming
yeah because they had a lot of requests
and how did it turn to this weed based
comedy well it was the only thing that
worked in this audience the weed see
when we're the city works a lot ta you
know right but when we got down here we
had a go right for the stoners because
that was what was going on you know and
so we played a club in Reseda in the
hotel and what sort of called and it was
owned by a crazy a big fan he saw us
work somewhere and so he hired us for
two nights and the first night first
night we had to do two shows but it was
a dance club and so the dancers had to
stop dance and sit down watch us do a
show and and that was not a good
combination so the first show of didn't
go very well because we're doing TNA
stuff and just didn't go over and so the
second show
teach and I got together I teach come on
man you're from here there must be a
character you could do and the night
before that we were standing outside and
this low rider pulls up and you go hey
man you tell me how to get to Reseda
Boulevard and she says oh you're on it
oh thanks man he's on the way and it was
that character and chief says yeah well
yeah we can do that character and then I
showed him that
kharbut this an old black comedian
showed me mr. pineapple you show me this
old taking a girl out on a date and you
just make the car up here by pretending
to wash it waxed you know just do the
mime and the car would appear and then
Cheech got in the car and he's driving
and then he was a red freak want to
write men and then I would come out and
we do our skits and and it went over
really well as soon as we started doing
you know we then in pills and stuff
everybody related so you feel like you
had that and then you just ran with it
oh yeah yeah didn't we just approved and
proved improve approved and so when we
met Lou Adler sauce and we never thought
about dinner record until we went to
Mina in his office he's got gold records
over here all over the place and we said
yeah we could do a record you know I was
a big Lenny Bruce fan anyway because
when I got high the first time I gave me
a joint and a mini Bruce record it's
good so nice so I studied that record
for months and so that was ingrained in
my head and so then when we started
doing the first bit we did was an
accident
Cheech got locked outside the the
mixdown room that we were in La Brea
you know old Charlie Chapman studio and
it was a little courtyard then where the
Sun was beating down was like noon and
it was hot and sheets as a method actor
and you had a put on all the costumes
you know they can get into character so
he's got all these costumes on he knocks
on the door and I was working the tape
recorder and I and when he knocked that
I looked up at the door and I didn't see
if the needle moved or not and so when
he not I didn't answer and then he
knocked again and I saw the needle moved
and so I said who isn't and I was
supposed to just open the door and let
him in and so there's a pause it's a
meme there it's me Let Me In come on man
so then it sends that word Dave's not
here came from that so I waited not
again you know long pause the pause
who is it and he's kidding man come on
man it's me I think the cops are you
come on hope no you know they went into
character
then then I'll just wait wait wait ace
waiting for me to open the door then
he'd knocked again and then it finally
goes it's me Dave man Dave that's a
David Nicholas yeah I go deeps not here
he blew it kicking the doors screaming
open the door you almost punched me and
but I said listen listen listen we don't
we played it back in and then Lou heard
it we recorded it not as funny but we
recorded it in next day it was all over
America Cheech and Chong was born Wow
and then how long after that just start
doing the movies seven years 78 we
started doing the movies because I got
tired to go to Australia did you guys
get accused of promoting pot oh yeah
like did you get like accused like you
you guys are a bad influence
oh yeah the youth and what was that like
yeah was nothing really there's more
publicity basically you know you know
it's just people you know you know what
really got what really I noticed anyway
it was the The Comedy establishment the
committee and the second city and all
those guys they hated us really hated us
why
except Bellucci Belushi was the only one
that loved us because Belushi was young
enough that he heard our records and it
influenced him but these other guys like
what's his name can't even think of his
name now maybe it's better I don't even
name them but they howard hesseman he he
was one of the committee members you
know you know WKRP in Cincinnati Shore
he was a big in and I got influenced by
him a big time
because I saw him during the committee
in in San Francisco and they had a
top-notch improv group there and they
were incredible and that's where I got
the inspiration to go up and turn the
strip club into a improvisational Club
I love improv but why didn't those guys
like you well because we were successful
we took what they were doing and took it
out of that that snotty theater theater
you know and so I'm so evolved see a
trickily you know that who does records
you know that kind of thing and next
thing you know tickets were bad back
then
well they ended up trying to do a record
but they had they had no clue
you know like see I'm a fighter man I've
been in the trenches forever you know
I've been playing black clubs as long as
I can remember and so I seen a lot of
humor a lot of stand-up comics you know
Redd Foxx was a real good friend of mine
did you ever do his comedy club his yeah
you never hear those Richard Pryor tapes
from the Redd Foxx comedy club they
would record him like doing his work
outs outs [ __ ] amazing stuff amazing
oh yeah Richard rich was a big friend
big fan
now see we had fans like that when
Cheech and I did the Comedy Store after
up in smoke we broke up with Lou we're
broke we had a hit movie no money
nothing what happened they stole your
money with Lou yeah
who's Lou Lou Adler okay he's the
producer and director of up in smoke and
although I wrote wrote it and directed
most of it especially the ending I'd
write it like again like again like I
said before I'm not into it into the
money part of it but how are you guys
broke well we weren't getting any money
from our life because we had to stop
touring because of the movie and so we
had no touring money coming in right and
so and then we got paid you know a
little bit of on the movie but nothing
compared to what we were making on the
road and it was a hugely successful
movie right
totally totally but that's way it is
giant just to just they took all the
money yeah I mean we got we get dribs
and drabs and at the end of the
accounting yeah the Hollywood accounting
yeah at the end of the period
you know when you forget when you've
gone on to something else and you get a
check oh that's nice yeah but so Cheech
and I went to the comedy store to get
our act together and Richard Pryor
helped us at the stage we had but five
sold-out shows Pauly Shore was a little
guy up in the light boots and watching
us because he was too young to be in the
in the crowd and as we walked up the
stage the first night Richard Serra he
held out his hand it was the greatest
compliment ever
[Applause]